for the past four decades nicholas cage
has been one of the most prolific and
entertaining actors in show business and
this weekend he'll bring his singular
style to the exciting action comedy the
unbearable weight of massive talent
which features the actor as well nick
cage an accomplished blockbuster action
star who's ready to retire however once
he's hired to attend the birthday party
of a wealthy superfan named hobby he
gets something of a second win and is
then recruited by a cia operative vivian
to channel some of his most iconic
fictional characters for a dangerous
government mission the film marks a
culmination of so many memorable moments
from cage's prodigious screen career
from his sprawling adventure stories to
syrian action dramas is this supposed to
be me
it's grotesque
i'll give you 20 000
so to celebrate this marvelously meta
role here's a look back at nicholas
cage's best action movies of all time
ranked
just before the mcu emerged as a
mainstay of the movie industry cage
became one of marvel's most fiery
superheroes of all time the title
character of 2007's ghost rider cage
stars is johnny blaze a reckless stunt
man who's forced to become the enforcer
of the demon mephistopheles
you
[Music]
hello johnny
stay away from me johnny has no choice
but to do the devil's bidding because as
a teenager he sold his soul to save his
father with johnny blaze cage's
performance manages to make the
character both ruthless and redeemable
haughty and heartfelt and condemned but
not contemptible it's a bold balancing
act that's perfectly matched by the
visually arresting action scenes that's
right
[Music]
there's something so satisfying about
seeing cage bring his skills to the
screen for films that have a bit of a
supernatural bent and drive angry is
another prime example of that cage stars
in this 2011 3d film is john milton a
man who escapes from hell armed with
nothing less than satan's own gun milton
is on a mission to get revenge against a
cult leader named jonah king a devil
worshiper who's murdered milton's
daughter and stolen his baby
granddaughter in order to sacrifice the
child and bring about hell on earth it's
clear throughout the flick that cage has
a lot of fun portraying this unholy
semi-human character who has absolutely
nothing left to lose not even his own
soul which makes for some hellishly good
action and stylish fight sequences with
an otherworldly flare better buckle up
for this high-speed film ride
[Music]
when it comes to cage's sci-fi surprises
2009's knowing is a must-see in the film
he portrays john kessler a grieving
widower and celebrated astrophysics
professor who gets his hands on a
bizarre list of dates and coordinates
that relate to major catastrophes
throughout recent history
[Music]
9 1101 but he soon discovers that the
numbers don't only relate to past
calamities they predict future ones he
finds himself right in the thick of the
chaos and begins to suspect that the
numbers point to some dark moments for
mankind in the near future as jon
scrambles to protect his child from the
voices that are creeping into his own
head and the impending disaster cage
delivers a syrian performance as a
parent who has to grapple with the
impossible before it's too late how am i
supposed to stop the end of the world
john woo's 2002 war film wind talker
centers on the navajo code talkers who
helped lead the troops to victory in
world war ii specific theater by using a
code that was indecipherable to enemy
forces in the film cage delivers a
riveting performance as sergeant joe
enders who's assigned to the crucial
undercover mission of protecting a code
talker private fanyasi from being
captured at all costs when he and his
fellow marines find themselves in an
ambush anders has to decide whether to
follow direct orders or forge his own
path forward through the skirmish as
enders cage brings both valor and
vulnerability to the role and what
results is a poignant picture about a
critical part to the allied success in
the war
some of cage's best roles are those that
allow him to show who he is rather than
spelling out the nuances of the
character through dialogue in 2013's joe
he plays something of an anti-hero with
a mysterious checkered past although joe
prefers to keep his own company he takes
a shine to a young man who stumbles onto
his work site looking for a job the boy
gary is hard-working but troubled and
soon joe finds out why the kid's father
is an abusive alcoholic though joe is
initially inclined to stay out of it as
the details of gary's home life come
into view he has no choice but to act
putting his own peace and security at
risk i'm gonna whip whoever's ass had
something to do with it put simply joe
isn't your average joe nor your
prototypical heroic figure and cage's
understated performance perfectly
captures the character in this
thoughtful action drama
in the 1993 neo noir thriller red rock
west cage plays michael williams a
combat veteran who stumbles into the
wrong place at the wrong time when he
heads to the town of red rock wyoming in
search of work he gets way more than he
bargained for when he's mistaken for a
hitman but when the actual hitman
portrayed by dennis hopper arrives the
real chaos begins so michael finds
himself in the middle of a deadly
domestic dispute with a hitman and a
powerful rage-filled sheriff on his tail
this stylish little thriller has a bit
of everything high speed chases clever
jailbreaks and some very surprising
twists and cages as charismatic as ever
in the role
if you want to see a film that allows
cage to channel every inch of his
ability to become unhinged on screen
look no further than werner herzog's
jarring crime drama bad lieutenant
portal call new orleans shoot him again
what fool the film features the actor as
one of the big easy's most corrupt cops
terence mcdonough terence might have
started out his career as a by the book
police officer but throughout the
shocking events of the film we watch him
unwind into a spectacular disaster whose
errant energy sends shockwaves
throughout the city he also deals with
his own deteriorating grasp on reality
as the consequences of his bad behaviors
bubble up and his grip on sanity
continues to wane terence chooses to
lean into his warped views of justice
leading to one breathlessly messy action
adventure and a truly riveting screen
turn for cage fans
the national treasure series is electric
from start to finish and is a definite
must-watch for nicholas cage fans in the
first film released in 2004 cage's
character benjamin franklin gates
decides he must steal the declaration of
independence in order to protect it and
the treasure map on the back of it
meanwhile in the second pick from 2007
he has to kidnap the actual president of
the united states in order to get his
hands on another map that leads to a
fabled city of gold in both films cage
imbues a character with a true sense of
honor unstoppable charm and a commitment
to protecting the most precious pieces
of the past even if that means being
completely reckless along the way here's
to the men who did what was considered
wrong
in order to do what they knew was right
with centuries old conspiracies and some
larger than life set pieces the national
treasure series is a wholesome double
adventure for all ages
the star-studded 2000 smash hit film
gone in 60 seconds has a whole lot of
glorious roadway action cage stars in
the film is randall memphis reigns a
retired car thief who has to quickly
assemble a crew who can help him track
down and steal 50 specific luxury cars
in the space of just three days to save
his brother's life together the group
puts petal to the metal to organize a
speedy series of heists to take place
simultaneously across the city of long
beach california what results is a
smashing series of highway chases
involving some of the snazziest cars
that have ever been seen on screen and
cages as always at his best as a
smooth-talking criminal who knows
exactly what he wants i don't have one
here however i
do have one in the warehouse superb
what else do you have in the warehouse
superhero movies may come in all shapes
and sizes but 2010's kick-ass is still
one of a kind i didn't say anything to
anyone i swear good move ass kick the
film centers on a nerdy kid named dave
who decides to try a super heroic alter
ego on for size because why not the
thing dave doesn't know though is that
he isn't the only person training to
deliver some homegrown justice amid his
rough shot crime-fighting adventures
kick-ass eventually meets hit girl and
her vengeance-seeking father big daddy
played by cage as big daddy cage is a
real riot parading around in a
batman-esque suit and coaching his
daughter on how to destroy armies of
goons all by herself the role is darkly
comedic and shows off cage's sublime
gift for blending action sequences with
quirky anecdotes and some very
off-the-wall character moments but it's
really no more painful than a punch in
the chest hey getting pushed to the
chest you're gonna be fine baby doll
cage is particularly gifted at playing
characters who have a lack of scruples
and absolutely no regrets and that's
certainly the defining characteristic of
his character in 2005's lord of war cage
stars in the pick is yuri orlov a
successful gun runner who delights in
providing arms to some of the world's
most dangerous individuals by the mid
80s my weapons were represented in eight
of the world's top 10 war zones
alongside his brother yuri becomes a
major player in the 1982 lebanon war and
catches the attention of interpol and
well let's just say he finds himself in
the middle of some very dangerous
conflicts azuri cages a complete enigma
bringing both humor and horror to a
story that's truly engaging and
intelligent can you bring me the gun of
rambo
part one two or three ridley scott's
2003 black comedy matchstick man
features cage at the absolute top of his
game his character roy waller is at once
a cavalier con artist and a desperately
unraveling individual with a lonely home
life his ability to smooth talk
unsuspecting marks and handing over
their hard-earned money is impressively
strong but he's also hanging on by a
thread when it comes to his own sanity
and sense of purpose i know i know but
this is an emergency hey buddy ever
heard of a lie have you ever been
dragged to the sidewalk and be until you
pissed blood things take a major turn
for roy when he's introduced to the teen
daughter he didn't know he had angela
and decides to embrace his dad's status
and teach her all he knows about running
the game you're ready for this i was
born ready
but i missed that day but as the stakes
of his heist reach new heights and his
mental health continues to waver roy has
to worry about more than just his own
financial interests for the first time
in his life things eventually culminate
into a gloriously chaotic climax with
some dynamite twists that keep you
guessing right until the end
1987's raising arizona was one of
nicholas cage's first major films but it
contains one of his all-time greatest
comedic action performances the movie
which helped bring the coen brothers
into the mainstream features the star as
high mcdonough a former convict who
marries a police officer named ed after
they decide they want to have children
but are unable to bear or adopt any
themselves hayan ed decided to kidnap
one of the quintuplet sons of a famous
furniture magnate and raise him as their
own though they initially try to raise
him as little junior and pass him off as
their own biological child things get
completely out of hand once a couple is
reacquainted with some of hai's former
pals from prison as well as other wild
card characters like hai's offensive
four men and a monstrous biker from hell
from there poor junior becomes the
unwinning centerpiece of some blackly
hilarious and action-packed exchanges
son you got a panty on your head
it's not often that a movie with intense
fighting and a complicated game of cat
and mouse can also be a meaningful
meditation on grief but that's exactly
what pig manages to pull off the film
features cage as rob a man who lives
completely off the grid in the forest
alongside his prized pig they spend
their days hunting truffles but when his
talented pig is stolen amid a violent
attack he has to return to the city to
face his mysterious past in order to
save her i'm looking for a truffle pig
i don't
i i don't understand though the film is
dripping with dread and features some
very satisfying moments of action it's
also refreshingly subversive and
emotionally engaging anchoring it all is
cage's sensational and critically
revered leading performance in the pick
which proves that even as accomplished
as he already is he's still got many
surprises up his sleeve
nicolas cage has always had some strong
rock and roll energy and the 2018 horror
flick mandy is a prime example of that
the psychedelic film features the actor
as red miller a reclusive logger who's
content to spend his quiet life with his
girlfriend mandy their piece is
completely shattered however when a
terrifying hippie cult attacks a couple
in their home with the help of some
demonic bikers in addition to being a
gonzo revenge story the film is a gory
scary sensory experience with cage's
deliciously berserk performance bringing
all the batting action home
welcome to the rock the cast of 1996's
the rock is a veritable who's who of
action movie all-stars from the era cage
stars as fbi agent dr stanley godspeed a
lab tech who has to work alongside a
group of navy seals on a highly
classified spy turned prisoner played by
sean connery to infiltrate the notorious
alcatraz prison after it's taken over by
a group of dangerous former marines
audiences are treated to a taut thrill
ride packed with plenty of punches and
as is the custom in any good cage movie
a lot of iconic moments
for a film that manages to incorporate
all the trappings of a traditional
action film john woo's face-off is still
an incredibly original thrill sure you
may have seen planes crash into hangers
high-speed boat chases and mega
shootouts on screen before but chances
are good that you've never seen these
events unfold during a blood feud
between two people wearing each other's
faces at least not until you check out
this 1997 classic you know i can
eat a page for hours the film features
cage and john travolta playing dual
roles with cage starting off as the
ruthless criminal caster troy before his
face is surgically switched with john
travolta's fbi agent sean archer with
their roles reversed and each man
pretending to be the other around their
family members and colleagues the
performances of cage and travolta are
exquisitely nuanced and off-kilter
wow
we've got something in common they also
both seem to be having the absolute time
of their lives in these roles which
amplifies the rush factor as this
memorable action ride brings the duo
together for an epic that's right face
off
there are many many roles that seem to
have been specifically crafted for
nicholas cage's unique screen talents
but 1997's conair truly hinges on his
particular gifts here he stars as
cameron poe a decorated combat veteran
who sent to prison after drunkenly
killing a man who attacked his wife
while incarcerated he ends up on board a
prison transport plane with the
country's most hardened criminals who
scheme to take over the plane and escape
from custody for cage fans this film has
a little bit of everything that makes
him such a hollywood legend the
character is tough but vulnerable
serious but also self-aware and he has
some unforgettable one-liners that only
he can deliver i said
put the bunny
back in the box put simply when it comes
to nick cage's most iconic action films
conair truly nails the landing with all
of these amazing performances under his
belt it's no wonder cage manages to
corral such intense pandemonium from the
likes of hobby and the unbearable weight
of massive talent a must-see theatrical
experience you should catch with friends
and all its action-packed glory this
weekend check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite movies are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
you